[Music]
this morning on the dish chef Lorena
Garcia born in Venezuela she enjoyed
cooking as a child and while she started
out pursuing a law career she found her
heart was in the kitchen after earning a
culinary degree
she took cooking jobs all over the world
and that experience helped her develop
the globally influenced Latin cuisine
she now serves at chica her hot spot in
the Venetian Hotel in Las Vegas chef
Lorena Garcia good morning welcome to
the dish this morning thank you so much
I'm so excited to be here we're so
excited by this table we brought you
chica right here so you know if I can
tell you what we brought we have our
famous buñuelos I'd actually want an
episode of Top Chef Masters in the
competition with this is absolutely
delicious this is my version of mac and
cheese so in a few I'll start there
instead of using pasta I use Peruvian
corn a little bit of hearts of palm you
know Parmesan cheese on top so it's nice
and creamy and delicious this is one of
my biggest sellers is a black lentil a
quinoa
cazuelas like a casserole with
Argentinean tremble a river of
Venezuelan CAPRISA then you have our
house wakka moly with a repeaters a
toast on sito's platen Ito's you have my
version of hoppin Jose and at the end my
cocktail one of my favorites called
Peppino Sandia in Salvation of gin and
tonic with a little bit of a crack she's
only precious Ament
you started cooking essentially at a
very young age do you have that first
food memory that you can share yes I
remember I was like about six or seven
years old and I decided to go into the
kitchen and make those other pitas that
you see over there and eggs and you know
coffee and I call my mom and my dad and
you know my brother and you know I
thought that I was doing like an amazing
thing so I did a picnic in the middle of
the living room the kitchen was a total
mess but hey I had a breakfast I
mentioned chica your restaurant in the
Venetian in Vegas you are the first
Latina chef there which which is
important to you it is it is extremely
important and I am
it's really happy and and and cannot be
a better time for us there a Jang Hong
Kong 50x and of course a group of the
venetie have been very gracious to you
know make my dream come true what was
the biggest challenge in opening this
the biggest challenge you know there is
a lot of challenges I think they keeping
the quality at that scale you know Las
Vegas its Las Vegas you know you have to
be up to par in terms of the amount of
coverage that we do so for me it's very
important that the quality of the dishes
that I make for two three four people is
the saying that we may four five six
hundred people and you you travel
globally and worked globally to sort of
get what your style is how did that
influence yes all very much so as soon
as I finish culinary art and while I was
going to school you know I just traveled
the world went to Paris I trained at the
Ritz
I spent months and months in the south
of Italy so that's my kind of French
style cuisine classically trained and
then South America the places that I
lived like Venezuela Argentina Mexico we
mentioned we mentioned that you
originally went to law school school for
law following your mother and your
brothers steps but something changed and
you for a time thought you made a
mistake I did because we righted so the
first job offer that I got I go into a
lot a lot of firm and when I saw the
books you know going to the ceiling I'm
like this is not for me so I literally
resigned the first day I got hired you
resign the right guys I'm going to
culinary school I have to do what I
budgeted about and this is noted why why
yeah well have you signed the dish now I
asked you if you could have a meal with
anyone past or present whatever I would
love to cook for Michelle Obama and just
have a conversation with her and just
pick her brain I think she's
unbelievable amazing yeah as are you and
this meal is spectacular thank you so
much my pleasure for more on chef Lorena
Garcia and the dish you can head to our
website at CBS this morning calm